avec nous Pierre Olivier Pineau il est
titulaire de la chair de gestion du
secteur de l'énergie HEC Montréal merci
beaucoup d'être l'homme monsieur Pinot
bonsoir vous vous étiez montré un peu
sceptique lorsqu'on avait annoncé qu'on
avait choisi myco Sebia pour diriger
Hydro-Québec c'est un financier qui
provient pas du secteur de l'énergie
est-ce que votre avis change un peu à la
lumière de ce qu'il a dit aujourd'hui
oui j'étais rassuré par son discours
parce qu'on avait jamais vraiment
entendu monsieur Sebia sur ces questions
là et donc aujourd'hui c'est la première
journée où on pouvait partager des idées
certains éléments de sa vision et
surtout il est arrivé avec une approche
très humble en disant qu'il allait
écouter prendre le temps et j'ai
beaucoup aimé ça de regarder toutes les
options parce que il va falloir
véritablement regarder les options et ne
pas
ressortir les les choix du passé les
vieilles caisses et puis ressortir les
projets il faut vraiment créer innover
et ça c'est un avantage en fait ce qu'on
pouvait lui reprocher de pas venir du
secteur de l'énergie ça peut être en
fait une un atout parce que il arrive
avec un regard neuf et ça ça pourrait
être une très bonne chose parce que ça
vous a pas surpris lorsqu'il a dit le
nucléaire est aussi sur la table non ça
ne me surprend pas parce que tous ceux
qui regardent vraiment ce que ça prend
pour décarboner un complètement une
économie voilà la quantité d'électricité
qui est nécessaire le Québec on échoyait
donc on pourrait se passer du nucléaire
mais nos voisins eux plus difficiles et
on pourrait jouer un rôle régional avec
du nucléaire il faut pas fermer cette
porte là même si c'est certainement pas
une priorité à court terme bon alors
l'objectif étant évidemment entre autres
d'augmenter la production la façon de le
faire on a clairement laissé entendre au
gouvernement qu'on était favorable au
privé monsieur Sebia a dit aujourd'hui
tout de suite non non elle a
privatisation évidemment mais lui aussi
son réintégré des entreprises privées
dans le développement par exemple de
projet éolien solaire etc donc on
conserve le modèle monsieur Pinault
est-ce que c'est le bon modèle alors
c'est un modèle qui nous a bien servi
jusqu'à maintenant là Monsieur c'est
bien arrive au pouvoir d'Hydro-Québec
mais il y a aussi une réforme du secteur
de énergie que monsieur fizzbone est en
train de préparer pour l'automne et ça
ça va aussi rebrasser les cartes
monsieur Sebia devrait se positionner
par rapport à cette réforme là je suis
pas sûr qu'il ait été au coeur ou qu'il
soit au coeur de discussion donc en fait
il pourrait y avoir des frictions à
venir mais on le verra c'est certain
qu'il faut changer la manière
d'organiser le secteur parce que les
défis sont elles qu'on peut pas juste
reprendre les solutions du passé et les
réappliquer le privé a toujours fait
partie du secteur électrique québécois
évidemment hydro-Québec a pris beaucoup
de place et c'est une bonne chose mais
il y a beaucoup à faire alors il y a de
la place pour beaucoup de joueurs et je
pense qu'il y a de la place pour des
joueurs privés des joueurs
communautaires des municipalités et
Hydro-Québec évidemment le mot je crois
qui a été prononcé le plus souvent dans
toutes les entrevues qu'il a accordé
monsieur Sebia aujourd'hui c'est le mot
prospérité il dit on est capable de
combiner un Québec prospère et un Québec
sobre en carbone c'est ça priorité on a
l'impression c'est ce qui s'est dégagé
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est la bonne
priorité
alors je crois que oui c'est la bonne
priorité maintenant après ça va être la
manière de le faire c'est évident que le
gouvernement de actuel de Monsieur Lego
mise beaucoup sur la prospérité
rattraper un certain retard économique
qu'on aurait par rapport à l'Ontario
donc c'est certain que là il y a une
convergence avec la pensée de Monsieur
Lego et c'est pour ça j'imagine qu'il a
été choisi maintenant il va falloir
faire attention si c'est vraiment que
des nouveaux projets sans améliorer
notre productivité énergétique là mon
avis ça serait une erreur parce qu'on
est une société qui consomme beaucoup
d'énergie pas forcément de la meilleure
manière il y a vraiment forte à faire
pour devenir plus prospère en consommant
moins et il a beaucoup sorti la carte
des nouvelles de la nouvelle offre et ça
c'est la carte que j'aimerais voir un
peu moins rapide une carte il a sorti
qui a peut-être surpris il a laissé
entendre que oui il y a la transition
énergétique on veut augmenter la
production médias énormément de chantier
à mener chez Hydro-Québec améliorer la
résilience du réseau le service à la
clientèle aussi le bouquin insister
là-dessus plusieurs petits postes dont
on parle moins souvent mais qui vont
nécessiter des investissements très
importants est-ce que ça va venir gruger
ça monsieur Pinault la capacité
d'Hydro-Québec à investir dans le grand
chantier de la transition énergétique je
ne crois pas parce qu'il est au Québec
n'est pas le seul joueur de la
transition énergétique Hydro-Québec un
rôle très important à jouer comme vous
l'avez dit il y a beaucoup de travail à
faire sur les infrastructures existantes
il faut aussi transformer les modes de
consommation hydro-Québec a annoncé 25
terawatters d'économies d'énergie visée
pour 2030 ça ne se fera pas avec le
statu quo donc il faut vraiment faire
des transformations et c'est là où le
rôle de partenaire et d'autres acteurs
va être très importants c'est là où
d'autres investisseurs que Hydro-Québec
vont pouvoir justement mener certains
projets éoliens peut-être solaire
peut-être de géothermie même pour le
chauffage des bâtiments c'est une option
qui est sous-utilisée au Québec donc il
y a plusieurs éléments qui doivent être
développés et il faut s'assurer que
l'écosystème de l'énergie soit bien
encadré mais avec des partenaires autour
d'Hydro-Québec et que Hydro-Québec ne
doit pas être le seul acteur de la
transition et pas le seul acteur et pas
le seul homme qui décide c'est-à-dire
monsieur c'est bien dit j'arrive je
consulte mes équipes je ferai ce qu'il y
a de mieux pour Hydro-Québec et pour les
Québécois et je ne serai pas le pion du
gouvernement en fait c'est ce qui
laissait entendre est-ce que ça ça vous
rassure oui ça me rassure puis c'est
certain que on a vu monsieur c'est bien
n'est pas la marionnette de monsieur
Legault de Monsieur fils gibben donc
c'est une très bonne chose c'était le
danger dans le choix d'un PDG de d'avoir
quelqu'un qui n'aurait pas une
crédibilité une personnalité forte et
donc là le choix du gouvernement et
certainement réussi à ce niveau là
évidemment on va voir ce que ça va
donner mais c'est ces propos aujourd'hui
me donnent plus d'optimistes que j'avais
initialement on verra maintenant il
devra faire ses preuves évidemment
monsieur Pinot merci beaucoup d'avoir
été là ça m'a fait plaisir merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]